Alexandra Ocasio Cortez makes her
presence known big democratic cities
engage in big crony capitalism and the
Muller investigation heats up again I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
well brand new faces in brand new places
we get to watch as the incoming Congress
comes in and you know participates in
some shenanigans we will talk about all
of that plus the Muller investigation
and a non shocking report on a global
warming research report that it turns
out was being skewed in a particular
direction I will let you guess that
direction but first let's talk about
your finances so Dems have retaken the
house obviously that is not going to be
great for the economy they're going to
be involved in attempting new
regulations they're going to be shutting
down the attempts to make the tax cuts
permanent they're going to be doing an
awful lot of things that aren't going to
be great for the business climate in the
country right now and that means that
you might want to think a little bit
more about diversify your funds right
now you should take a look at Birch gold
can you really afford another hit if the
stock market should take a serious hit
like it took in 2007-2008 when the S&P
dropped 50% instead you might want to
think about doing a little bit of
hedging hedge against inflation hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified your should be - I'm not
talking about taking all your money out
of the stock market and putting it in
gold I'm talking about taking some of
your money and putting it into precious
metals because they've never been worth
zero and again they are a good hedge
against inflation and instability the
company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move your IRA are eligible 401
K into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver which is perfect for folks
who want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from future
geopolitical uncertainty Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews a
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau check them out right now contact
Birch gold group again a free
information kit on physical precious
metals - comprehensive 16-page kit
showing how gold and silver can protect
your savings go to birchgold.com slash
been ask all of your questions get your
answers and then when you're ready to
invest talk to my friends at Birch gold
birchgold.com slash Bend that's WWB our
gold calm /ban go check it out okay so
the assumption going into the new
Democratic controlled Congress is that
things were going to be pretty terrible
and I think that assumption holds fairly
true I think that Democrats are going to
launch an endless round of
investigations into everything Trump
related the vast majority of which will
not only be irrelevant but
counterproductive I think that the
Democrats are going to hold up
the business of government for
ridiculous proposals like massive carbon
taxes for example I think Democrats are
going to be just as bad at governance as
they ever were back when they were in
control of the house from 2006 to 2010
and Nancy Pelosi will be Speaker of the
House again but there is gonna be some
fun Democratic infighting or at least
there are indicators that there may be
some funds m ik rata confiting
that was the early indication anyway so
Alexander Ocasio Cortez who is the
progressive leftist darling beloved of
the of the radical members of the base
she went to a sit-in outside speaker
Pelosi's office and I want to show you
that I think that Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez well she doesn't know squat about
economics well she doesn't understand
politics in a very basic way she is a
canny young politician she's a lot canny
or than she's being given credit for and
the reason I say this is because the
headlines that emerge from this
situation yesterday in Congress are not
actually consonant with what happened
yesterday in Congress so there's this
big sit-in outside speaker Pelosi's
office they're a bunch of people who are
protesting saying they want a new
subcommittee formed on climate change
that has the power to push legislation
and Ocasio Cortez shows up at this big
sit-in outside it gets all sorts of
press
[Music]
save our planet or generation our future
okay so yeah everybody would say well
well look at her she's really going
there to stands up to Nancy Pelosi and
really push Nancy Pelosi hard from the
left well this is much more of an
inside-outside game excuse me
this is much more of an inside-outside
game well we are watching instead is
Nancy Pelosi pretending to be the
moderate and then Alexandra Ocasio
cortes getting to be the person who
pulls Nancy Pelosi in the radical left
direction and is it's a good piece of
politicking I will say Nancy Pelosi then
issued a statement saying we are
inspired by the energy and activism of
the many young activists and advocates
leading the way in the climate crisis
which threatens the health economic
security and futures of all of our
communities I have recommended to my
House Democratic colleagues that we
reinstate the Select Committee to
address the climate crisis House
Democrats ran on and won on our bold
campaign for one trillion dollar
investments in our infrastructure
they'll make our communities more
resilience the climate crisis while
creating 16 million new good-paying jobs
across the country
we welcome the presence of these
activists we strongly urged the Capitol
Police to allow them to organize and
participate in our democracy in other
words Nancy Pelosi was fine with this
protest she wasn't standing up to the
protest it wasn't that Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez was there to actually press Nancy
Pelosi in fact right after this happened
she walked out and she talked about how
wonderful Nancy Pelosi was she said
really what I'm here to do is to support
the folks who are here and she talked
about how much she admired Nancy Pelosi
at this point that Ala pundit was making
over at hot air so I think that this is
a bit of good politicking from Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez who it turns out is quite
good at this yesterday she had an entire
Instagram in which she walked around her
new digs over at the Capitol building
and she took pictures and she showed how
there are tunnels underneath Congress
which are pretty cool and she talked
about how it felt like being at Hogwarts
and all of this is hip and young and
cool yeah this is something that
Republicans should be worried about is
that if folks like Alexandra of cosmic
Cortes turn out not to just be a bunch
of babbling morons when it comes to
economics but they actually can take
that babbling idiocy and then apply it
with some serious politicking that is a
problem now again I think that Ocasio
Cortez is is Kenny and
and how she has deployed her resources
here so for example she was making a big
fuss last week about how she doesn't
have the ability to rent a house in
Washington DC well then she filed her
financial disclosure reports it turns
out that she has something like $15,000
$15,000 in her savings in her checking
account as of April and she has
something like $50,000 in stocks and
bonds in her savings account which means
that yes she actually does have the
ability to rent an apartment in
Washington DC as often happens with a
lot of candidates there's a there's a
great amount of posturing about how they
stand with the working folks but when it
turns out that those problems don't
actually apply to them they just sort of
fib about it and that seems to be the
case with Alexandra Ocasio Cortez as
well now on the climate change point
there's a big story out today that is
going to get very little play beyond the
original story in The Washington Post
The Washington Post did cover it but
it's not going to be covered very much
beyond that in for example the nightly
news the story is this with regard to
global warming
a major study that claimed the oceans
were warming much faster than previously
thought was apparently baseless there
were key errors in the study this
recording Chris Mooney and Brady Dennis
over at the Washington Post and this
does beg a question which is why is it
that every single time there's an error
in a climate change study it tends to
benefit people who say the climate
changes a catastrophe when was the last
time there was an error in a climate
change study in which people said you
know what it turns out that we
underestimated the amounts of climate
change that was going to happen I can't
think of a single time yet how many
times is the climate change community
overstated the amount of damage that
climate change is going to do routinely
the modeling has always been off on the
on the heavier side has never been off
on the lighter side the reason this
matters is because economic intervention
attempts to skew the economy of the
United States or the global economy on
the basis of global warming would cost
trillions and trillions of dollars it
would cost people lives it really would
in developing countries particularly
where they actually need carbon-based
fuels in order to survive it would
severely crimp quality of life in
Western countries as well in order for
you to make the claim that ought to
happen you ought to be you really should
have to make a claim that something dire
is in the works but the climate change
community instead of actually
substantiating that with the best
available resource a research it turns
out that they've
skewed the research at every available
turn and again I'm not somebody who
believes the climate change isn't
happening
I think climate change is happening I
think the majority of it is due to human
interaction with the climate but I do
not think that that necessarily means we
have a catastrophe on our hands that
requires a complete rewriting of the
economy in a socialist direction which
seems to be the actual goal of a lot of
these folks here's the story from the
Washington Post quote scientists believe
a major study that claimed the Earth's
oceans are warming faster than
previously thought
now say their work contained inadvertent
errors that made their conclusions seem
more certain than they actually are
shocker two weeks after the high-profile
study was published in the journal
Nature its authors have submitted
corrections to the publication The
Scripps Institution of Oceanography hope
home to several of the researchers
involved all also noted the problems in
the scientists work and corrected a news
release on its website which previously
had asserted that the study detailed how
the Earth's oceans have absorbed 60%
more heat than previously thought
unfortunately we made mistakes here said
Ralph Keeling a climate scientist at
Scripps who is a co-author of the study
I think the main lesson is that you work
as fast as you can to fix mistakes when
you find them well the other main lesson
is that when you find data that are too
good to be true in a political direction
that you like maybe you should take a
second look at the data itself it this
tends to happen a lot in the scientific
community studies that back a leftist
point of view our ballyhooed they are
talked about as though they have proven
the case of the left when in fact
sometimes the data is just not right
the central problem according to Keeling
came in how the researchers dealt with
the uncertainty in their measurements as
a result the findings suffer from too
much doubt to definitively support the
papers conclusion about how much heat
the oceans have absorbed over time the
central conclusion of the study that
oceans are retaining ever more energy as
more heat is being trapped within
Earth's climate system each year is in
line with other studies that have drawn
similar conclusions and it hasn't
changed much despite the errors but
Keeling said the author's
miscalculations mean there's a much
larger margin of error in the findings
which means researchers can weigh in
with less certainty than they thought
and this has been one of the other
factors in looking at climate change if
you look at the IPCC report that
recently came out a month ago that IPCC
report specifically talked about the
levels of uncertainty with regard to the
level of climate change those occurring
or the level of damage that would occur
because of climb
change but nobody ever talks about level
of certainty they never talk about
margins of error instead they treat the
bottom line finding as though it is
written in stone as though it is 100
percent certain and that simply is not
true right the study's lead author was
Laurie was plenty of Princeton
University other researchers were with
the institutions in China Paris Germany
the US National Center for Atmospheric
Research and geophysical fluid dynamics
laboratory nature said maintaining the
accuracy of the scientific record is of
primary importance to us as publishers
we recognize our responsibility to
correct errors in papers that we have
published and listen they should correct
errors good on them but the original
study suggested that the amount of heat
that was being absorbed by the oceans
was very high probability 60% above what
they thought which meant there would be
less time than originally thought to
curb greenhouse gas emissions and it
drew considerable media attention but
then it turns out that there was a major
problem with the research there is a
britain-based researcher named Nicholas
Lewis and he said so far as I can see
their method vastly underestimates the
uncertainty as well as biasing up
significantly nearly 30 percent the
central estimate this is basically just
some guy in Britain who happens to know
what he's talking about who blogged
about it very often the climate change
community has simply dismissed such
concerns out of hand how could we
possibly take seriously people who blog
for a living as opposed to the great
majority of scientists who agree with us
the skewing of science for political
purposes is extraordinarily dangerous
stuff especially because it does have
ramifications for what we do in our
everyday lives it has ramifications for
regulation and legislation and it's not
just happening in terms of climate
change it's also happening in terms of
it gender and we'll get to that in just
one second but first let's talk about
the climate right now I'm around the
country millions of Americans are
turning up the furnace for the first
time and then spending a week freezing
at night why because they didn't change
out their air filters and it turns out
it burned out their system this costly
mistake is completely avoidable by
regularly replacing the air filters at
filter by calm America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses you can choose from
over 600 sizes including custom options
that ship free within 24 hours and for
people who like to kick the can down the
road filter by actually gives you 5
percent off your order when you
subscribe for auto replacement which
means that you don't have to manually go
in and get new filter
every time they just come on a regular
schedule this is so much easier than
going to the hardware store having the
special order filters plus these filters
are great and they're made in the United
States filter by will save you time
money and help you breathe better as
well that's filter Bui comm filter by
comm tell them that we sent you here at
the Ben Shapiro show again there's no
reason for you to suffer through crummy
air that is gonna make you feel gunky
insides can make you feel more sick and
it could burn out your entire HVAC
system doing serious damage to your
budget go check it out filter by comm
filter Bui comm and tell them that we
sell you okay other areas in which the
left has been skewing science in order
to reach particular political
conclusions this is an amazing amazing
story this one's out of Berkeley so we
talked about a couple of weeks ago the
Trump administration making a
determination that for purposes of
federal contracting for purposes of
interpretation of federal law at the
executive level that male and female
mean biological male and female does not
mean transgender male or female doesn't
mean people who identify one way or
another it means that we are going to
identify you by your actual sex we're
not going to use the made-up term gender
in order to skew things and say that
you're a woman when you are actually a
biological male and the entire left one
knots how dare they say this there's a
full article in The New York Times
suggesting that sex doesn't even exist
forget gender sex is a spectrum which is
nonsense sex is not a spectrum the
dichotomous nature of human sex is the
reason that we can procreate were it not
for the fact that there are two sexes
and not 11 it would be very difficult
for humankind to actually have
descendants okay well the problem with
bad science is that it creates bad
social results and here's one example a
Christian student senator this is
according to Cassie Dylan over daily
wire a Christian student senator at the
University of California Berkeley is now
being ousted from her position after
abstaining abstaining from a resolution
that condemns the Trump administration
for considering narrowing the definition
of gender I'm not kidding you abstaining
so this student senator a Christian
refused to vote along with a resolution
that condemned the Trump administration
for saying men are men and women are
women and now the student senator is
going to lose her position the
resolution was introduced on October
31st in response
Isabella Chao gave a statement
explaining why she could not vote on the
resolution
her Christian beliefs she says my god is
one who assigns immeasurable value to
and desires to allow the each and every
human being in God's eyes and therefore
my own every one of you here today and
in the LGBTQ community as a whole is
significant valid wanted and loved even
if and when our views differ that said I
cannot vote for this bill without
compromising my values and my
responsibility to the community that
elected me to represent them as a
Christian I personally do believe that
certain acts and lifestyles conflict
with what is good right and true I
believe that God created male and female
at the beginning of time and designed
from error and design for marriage
between one man and one woman for me to
love another person does not mean that I
silently concur one at the bottom of my
heart I do not believe that your choices
are right or best for you as an
individual after lengthy conversations
with many of my community leaders and
advisors I've chosen to abstain from
voting on these bills tonight
the resolution condemned the proposed a
title nine changes that limited gender
identity to physical sex the tea party
of which Chou's member student action
then cut ties with her claiming there
inconsistencies between her beliefs and
the party including perspectives on
reproductive health and wellness
resource abstaining was simply too much
and of course she got called the bidat
bigoted Teddy Lake a student senator who
introduced the resolution condemned
shall and said tonight was a harrowing
reminder of the kind of bigotry that
persists in contemporary society and
more specifically sits across from me on
the Senate floor in just second don't
talk more about how bad science results
in bad public policy this is a very
obvious case I mean it's really
astonishing so again a Christian student
who was ousted from her seat in the
Berkeley Student Senate for having the
temerity to say I'm a Christian I can't
vote for this thing because it violates
my values and so she abstained she
didn't vote against it and thus she was
labeled a bigot Teddy Lake again the
student senator who introduced the
resolution he said I cannot fathom the
amounts of cognitive dissonance required
to make a statement as disingenuous and
harmful as the one senator Chao made
tonight the contradictions present in
her speech are frankly disturbing and
irreconcilable perhaps what most offends
me though is senator Chows outrageous
ask that we as the Senate class respects
her beliefs as she does are why is that
outrageous and the answer is is not
outrageous but when you believe that
your view is fact and everybody else's
view is just an opinion then you get to
crack down on them then you like says it
to that end I
to clarify that what senator channel
expressed tonight were not police at all
they were not beliefs at all they were
hateful prejudices that deserve nothing
less than the strongest condemnation for
myself my community and my colleagues I
have no obligation to entertain or
engage with individuals who deny my
right to exist loudly and proudly as a
member of the lgbtq+ community
okay well this particular student
senator never did any of that but again
when you back political opinion with bad
science you ends up believing that your
opinions are fact and therefore can be
crammed down on anybody else and their
opinions are not opinions but in fact
simply hateful knee-jerk prejudice tchau
then sent in op-ed to the school
newspaper The Daily Cal but that
happened was rejected because it
reinforces her original statement which
they deem that utilized rhetoric that is
homophobic and transphobic by the daily
Cal standards pretty astonishing the
queer Alliance Resource Center condemned
Chau and called for her resignation at
the Senate meeting last week students
protested hundreds and even had a large
banner that said senator Chao resign now
pretty astonishing stuff pretty sound of
astonishing stuff
Chao gave The Daily wire a statement
said for me and the church here at
Berkeley free speech is an issue that
has been highlighted but is not the
primary issue at stake here as one of my
staffers put it this is people issue
people who feel hurt and unable to
reconcile how the traditional Christian
worldview can profess to love LGBTQ
individuals while disagreeing with their
lifestyles and the promotion of their
identities even if the church continues
to be misunderstood and slandered our
responsibility is not to shout our
beliefs loudly above the noise but to
emulate the unconditional love and truth
of Jesus so obviously this is a hateful
terrible person and we know so because
science speaking of which I do love this
this story this is the the best story of
the day or worst story of the day
depending on how you define it
apparently there is a situation that has
now arisen in which a school has
punished a male teacher for refusing to
watch a naked girl in the boys locker
room what does that mean well it means
that again bad science with regard to
sex and gender lead to pretty terrible
public policy ramifications in this
particular case a Florida School
District is according to joy Pullman
over at the Federalist in Florida School
District allowed a self-described
transgender female
student regular access to the boys
locker room with no advance warning to
the boys or their parents which again if
a boy walked into the girls locker room
and didn't proclaimed himself a female
then we would understand that this would
be sexual harassment at the very least a
transgender boy meaning a woman a girl
walks into a locker room without telling
the other guys first and that's not a
problem at all and if guys are
uncomfortable then that's their fault
for being uncomfortable
yeah that's not imposing on anybody the
first time at this girl walked in she
clawed boys literally with their pants
down causing them embarrassment and
concerned by the fact that they'd been
observed changing by an obvious girls
had a complaint letter to Pasco County
school district from Liberty Council a
pro bono constitutional law firm
school administrators forbade teachers
from talking about the change and
ordered a male PE teacher to supervise
the potentially undressed girl in the
Chaska middle school locker room the
letter says when he refused to knowingly
place himself in a position to observe a
minor female in the nude or otherwise in
a state of undress administrators told
him quote he will be transferred to
another school as disciplined for not
doing your job in the locker room so now
we are forcing male PE teachers to view
undressed girls who say they are boys
when we all know that if a male PE
teacher looked at an undressed girl in
the locker room who did not believe she
was a boy he would be fired and possibly
prosecuted but now this has to be forced
crammed down the throats of people who
don't want to engage in conduct they
believe would be unbecoming to their job
and would cause serious problems with
sexual harassment for example bad
science leads to bad results
identifying science with your opinion
also leads to bad results whether we are
talking about climate change or whether
we are talking about gender studies or
any of the rest of this sort of stuff
well in just a second I want to talk
about the great irony of Democrats who
apparently spend most of their days
talking about terrible big corporations
are how they how they rip people off how
they how they harm the little guy and
then they bribe those corporations as
fast as they possibly can we'll talk
about that in just a second first let's
talk about your imminent demise well I
hope it's not imminent I hope that you
live another hundred years I hope that
you live for long but at some point
we're all gonna plotz and that means
that you need life insurance you need to
make sure that your family is taken care
of in case god forbid something should
go wrong having life insurance is
actually a pretty
feeling it's nice to know that if
anything were to happen to you your
family wouldn't have to start a GoFundMe
and policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance online in just two
minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed over
20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and auto insurance and home insurance if
you care about it they can cover it so
if you've been avoiding getting life
insurance because it's difficult or
confusing give policy genius a try just
go to policy genius.com get your quotes
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go to
policy genius comm again only takes a
couple of minutes to get this thing done
and then it's done and you don't have to
worry about it ever again
and by the time you would have to worry
about it you'd be dead so wouldn't
matter you'd make sure that you had life
insurance all locked up go to policy
genius comm and again get those quotes
and apply in minutes it's the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance
ok so Democrats like Bill DeBlasio who
spend their entire careers ripping on
corporations corporations bad business
bad government good well it turns out
that in New York and Virginia Democrats
are more than happy to dump piles of
money just doodles of money on top of
big corporations like Amazon on Tuesday
Amazon announced as we talked about
yesterday that it would split it's much
ballyhooed
HQ to its headquarters to between two
cities New York and Crystal City an area
just outside Washington DC now unless
you think that Crystal City is actually
a beautiful city made of crystal it is
not as a pile of cement warehouses so
it's basically like if Emerald City were
made of Formica New York is obviously
heavy Democratic territory the
headquarters will be located in Queens
and the Congress person there is
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez so good luck to
everyone involved Northern Virginia is a
similarly Democratic area and the
governor there is a Democrat of course
so what goodies did Democrats give that
Jeff Bezos and Amazon for the privilege
of hosting in their new headquarters
well the state of Virginia is going to
give the Amazon some five hundred
seventy three million dollars million
dollars to produce twenty five thousand
jobs
Arlington will give Amazon a twenty
three million dollars over 15 years as
Garrity points out Arlington is actually
raising taxes in order to pay Amazon to
locate there now
to be clear virginia is giving amazon
tax breaks it's not necessary it's not
the same thing as them just dumping
money on amazon but they're doing them
all sorts of goodies including the
ability to have prior notice of FOIA
requests regarding government documents
related to amazon which is pretty
incredible meanwhile new york opened its
goody bag as well
governor andrew cuomo who is thick as a
block of wood and Mayor Bill DeBlasio
who is fond of dropping groundhogs they
grinned through in the announcement that
the state would give Amazon some two
billion dollars in tax credits and other
incentives they received direct
incentives direct incentives meaning
cash of 1.5 to 5 billion dollars for
creating 25,000 jobs in an average of 61
thousand dollars per job created the New
York Times also reports the state also
offered a capital grant to the company
that could total as much as five hundred
million dollars right it's taxpayer
dollars going to Amazon so that Amazon
can build new offices it will also apply
for additional incentives through
existing city programs available to any
company tax experts said these programs
could amount to hundreds of millions of
dollars both New York and Washington DC
can expect rising housing prices strain
public services and additional tax
dollars spent on Amazon now listen there
is no bigger Amazon booster on planet
earth and I I'm one of the first
probably I think 1,000 Prime members I
am a huge Amazon fan I love what they do
I am a I'm an Amazon defender but this
is not capitalism this is not the free
market at work this is the government
giving subsidies and goodies to a
company to draw them to a particular
area and as I mentioned yesterday
there's a great irony and the folks who
are in New York and DC these men these
major Democrats New York and Virginia
these folks talking about how big
business is terrible and needs to be
regulated and taxed but then when we
want to bring some jobs to town we need
to get rid of the regulations and we
need to get rid of the taxes said well
guys you know it'd be a great way to
draw lots of business to your town would
be to get rid of these regulations and
taxes for everyone crony capitalism is
indeed alive and well in democratic
areas like New York and Northern
Virginia this used to be called
corruption right this used to just be
called corruption or at the very least
it was considered economic fascism if
you go back to the actual fascist system
of economics under both the the
Mussolini Italians
and the Nazi German system if you look
at how they ran economics who is
basically the government subsidizing
particular firms with taxpayer dollars
and giving them all sorts of goodies and
freedom from regulation in return for
those companies doing good things for a
particular administration or for the
government itself well this is the same
sort of economics it's kind of hilarious
that these Democrats you spend all their
days decrying corruption of corporations
you know the entire will occupy wall
street movement they pretend that this
is like Amazon's fault this is in the
Amazon's fault this is the government's
fault for deciding to go out of its way
to pay Amazon to do things if the
government were not a giant grab bag of
cash Amazon would have no capacity to
grab the cash now this did lead to a
little bit of confusion yesterday on the
right because Alexandre Ocasio Cortez we
talked about yesterday tweeted out that
Amazon is a billion dollar company and
it shouldn't receive hundreds of
millions of dollars in tax breaks and a
lot of people on there like yay
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez woo she's on our
side well in the same way that Occupy
Wall Street was not on our side
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez is not on our
side it's not the Democrats like
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez want less
government intervention in the economy
far from it she wants the government to
actually take over particular industries
and she doesn't she's not even against
crony capitalism she's very much in
favor of it when it favors firms that
she likes just doesn't like Amazon a
Philip Wegman of the Washington Examiner
points out that Ocasio Cortez her
website explicitly calls for quote the
electrification of vehicles sustainable
home heating distributed rooftop solar
generation and the conversion of the
power grid to zero emissions energy
sources all of which can only be
attempted through massive subsidies and
taxes and so we have here this is one of
those areas where the Democrats and the
Republicans are not that far apart
except in the size and the scope of the
giveaways when it comes to Democrats
they want to extend the Amazon model to
all of their favorite businesses and
sectors Republicans only want to extend
the Amazon model to a few of their
favorite business and sectors so
President Trump likes to do this for the
steel sector for example and President
Trump likes to do this for the auto
sector he wants to do it for the auto
sector here's the problem government do
good ISM means taking money from some
people and giving it to others that is
not what we call Pareto optimal
efficiency Pareto optimality is an
economic term
meaning any distribution of resources
that leaves everybody better off and no
one worse off so if you and I make a
trade goods for services I have money I
need you to do my plumbing for me I give
you the money you give me the plumbing
services we are now both better off this
is Pareto optimal right this is this has
created in an optimal situation
but anything that is not Pareto optimal
means you are taking from someone and
giving to somebody else and that is
killing efficiency in the process both
Republicans and Democrats engage in this
and it's really an ugly thing it's an
ugly thing and it's frankly an
unconstitutional thing it has nothing to
do what this is with the powers of the
federal government and when it comes to
state governments doing the same
generally the original state
constitutions were not designed to
actually fulfill all of the to do all of
these things well meanwhile President
Trump is apparently considering another
shake-up of his administration a lot of
chaos in the West Wing these days he
apparently is going to remove Department
of Homeland Security Secretary Christian
Nielsen and is looking at possible
replacements for John Kelly as well and
those include Nick Ayers who is vice
president Mike Pence's chief of staff
really good guy Nick Ayers he'd make a
terrific chief of staff John Kelly has
been shall we say less than right in the
chief of staff position in the Trump
administration he's caused a lot of
friction and a lot of conflict inside
the West Wing he is not particularly
politically astute and the great lie
that came about when he was originally
appointed chief of staff was that he was
going to be excellent at sort of keeping
everybody in line that obviously has
been wildly untrue nobody has been kept
in line by John Kelly instead he sort of
has an agenda all his own and that has
created some friction the White House
has not responded to a request for
comments on the timeline but it would be
sort of shocking if there isn't a major
shake-up inside the administration right
now you know I think the the shake-up in
the administration is is going to happen
pretty soon every take up the tap in so
far by the way has actually made the
administration better so I'm not opposed
to the shake-up in the administration
but sometimes how it's done is
uncomfortable for example yesterday the
first lady Melania Trump asked that the
White House sever ties with deputy
national security adviser Mira Ricardo a
spokesman for the first lady's office
said on Tuesday kind of rare for the
first lady's office to issue public
statements ripping staffers but she said
it is the position of the office of the
first lady that she no longer deserves
the honour of serving in the White House
which is oh boy that's the top staffer -
JA - John Bolton so that is again
lensing the lending a feeling of chaos
to the West Wing that they just don't
need right now in a second I want to
talk about the latest in the niemoller
indictments and all the rest I also want
to talk about a the media's complete
failure to do its job on a variety of
variety of issues but first let's talk
about how you can protect your online
security well look as a public figure
I'm constantly in fear that I will be
hacked or threatened online spied on I
don't want my emails compromised my
credit card number or online banking
passwords stolen but it happens to
millions of people every single year so
how can you protect yourself well the
company I trust to defend my online
security and privacy is expressvpn
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
connection by encrypting a hundred
percent of your network data hiding your
IP address that means nobody can record
or access your online activity download
expressvpn on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just the way you normally would you
click one button in your expressvpn app
and you are now protected expressvpn is
great for accessing content from
anywhere with VPN locations in 94
countries and blazing fast speeds as
well so go check them out right now the
nice folks at expressvpn have extended
special pricing of less than seven bucks
per month to all my fans so visit
expressvpn comm slash Ben to claim your
discount again that is expressive VPN
comm slash Ben to learn more you want to
keep all your online activity say if you
don't need people up in your business go
check it out expressvpn comm slash man
there's no that's the reason why it's
rated the world's number one VPN service
for Internet users expressvpn comm / Ben
okay well we're going to get into the
molar indictments and the latest on that
plus we have some real goodies in things
I like and things I hate today but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire comm and subscribe what do you do
you get the rest of this show live yet
the rest of the Andrew Clavin show live
the rest of the Michael Mills show live
also you get access to our Sunday
specials the complete version of our
Sunday specials this week Sunday special
features former Canadian Prime Minister
Stephen Harper is just a fantastic
person and in a really clever canny and
intellectually fascinating politician
here is a little bit of what that looks
like hi I'm Stephen Harper 22nd Prime
of Canada to join me on the bench
Shapiro show this week where we discuss
a lot of controversial issues as Donald
Trump trade immigration and my new book
right here right now politics and
leadership in the age of disruption a
lot of good stuff in that interview you
don't want to go check that out we have
all sorts of goodies another Kingdom you
get early access to you want to hear
Michael moles read to you and you want
to watch amazing art go check out
another Kingdom but you can only do that
by subscribing also make sure that if
you are in Pittsburgh tonight we are
speaking and this is my final speech
this year on the yif speaking tour we're
at the University of Pittsburgh tonight
6:30 p.m. Eastern you can catch the last
stop we're gonna be talking about a wide
variety of issues as always we will do
our famed Q&A and I will be speaking
specifically about right-wing and mostly
left-wing anti-semitism bring a friend
bring great questions bring a jacket
because it is indeed freezing out here
honestly I'm from California this is
unpleasant hope to catch you there make
sure that you show up also go follow us
over at YouTube or iTunes make sure you
leave us a review it always helps us we
have largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
so meanwhile President Trump even as he
experiences some chaos in the West Wing
we are awaiting news from the Muller
investigation a couple of things to be
made clear one President Trump has not
obstructed the Millar investigation that
is obvious if he had obstructed the
Millar investigation they would know in
the White House what's going on they
don't know in the White House what is
going on even though the Muller
investigation is taking place under the
auspices of the Department of Justice
Bloomberg is reporting the new
indictments from Special Counsel Robert
molars investigation of Russian
interference are expected this week CBS
says that citing multiple people with
knowledge of the investigation one of
the people claiming that they will be
indicted is conspiracy theory conspiracy
theorist jerome corsi
who made his name a few years back
claiming that he had proof that
president obama was in fact born in
kenya which he was not he told viewers
of his YouTube livestream broadcast on
Monday
he'd been cooperating with the inquiry
since receiving a subpoena from FBI
agents at his home in August he said he
expects to be indicted for some form or
other of giving false information in the
probe despite doing everything he could
to cooperate he said the possible
charges arose related to Roger stone who
of course is close friends with the
Trump campaign and Roger stone had ties
with Russia and WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange horseys lawyer David gray didn't
immediately respond to requests for
comment as of Monday night because it
turns out you know it's a really bad
idea
going in public and then talking about
your status as a possible indictment
target from the FBI that's always not
the smartest thing to do just as a
lawyer first rule of being a client to a
lawyer shut your face
don't go out and say things really
really dumb
any new indictments would come amid
recent turmoil at the Justice Department
of course the Democrats are looking
forward to trying to claim the man
Whittaker the new acting AG is
obstructing justice and preventing
indictments from coming down meanwhile
President Trump is apparently going to
answer written Russia probe questions
this week this is according to Reuters
President Trump is expected to provide
written answers to questions from the
special counsel investigating Russian
interference in the 2016 US presidential
election as soon as this week the
questions apparently relate only to
Moscow's involvement in the election not
obstruction which is good for Trump
because the fact is that Trump doesn't
actually there's no proof and there's
been no evidence
that Trump himself was involved in
Russian efforts to interfere in the
American election the the obstruction
stuff would be a lot tougher for him
because obviously would be targeting him
particularly even though as I say I
think obstruction at this point there's
no evidence for it either and it would
be baseless among the topics covered is
that June 2016 meeting between the
president's son Donald Trump jr. other
members of the Trump campaign team and a
group of Russians according to the
source that of course is not
particularly shocking that has always
been the big sore thumb in this entire
investigation for the Trump campaign was
that June 2016 meeting in which Donald
Trump jr. released emails publicly
showing that he had said to a Russian
friend of his with connections to the
Russian government that he would be
interested in hearing what a Russian
connected lawyer had to say about
defeating Hillary Clinton Rudy Giuliani
declined to comment
so did Peter Carr a spokesman for the
special counsel Trump's lawyers have
been negotiating with Muller's team
since last year over whether he's
actually going to sit for an interview
the question still has not been settled
the source said on Tuesday so you know
we will see how all of this shakes out I
really don't think that there's gonna be
an indictment brought against Trump or
anyone in his inner circle I think
there's a lot of talk going around right
now about Donald Trump jr. fearing that
he will be indicted for some reason
until we actually see the evidence and
see the indictment we're not gonna know
the answer to that however if this
entire debacle I mean if this entire
investigation comes down to nothing
these screams will never cease to be
heard across the land from the anchors
over at CNN from the left which has
fully expected for now two years that
Trump would basically be deposed from
office by the FBI for Russian
interference in the election and that
the thing about all of that is been a
complete waste of time
imagine if the Democrats instead of
spending the last two years whining
about Russian interference in the
election and and again I think that
Russian interference in the election is
a terrible thing the Russians should be
stopped from doing it but instead of
them suggesting that Trump is an
illegitimate president because he worked
hand in glove with the Russians imagine
if they just spent the last couple of
years focusing in on president Trump's
other myriad foibles they did enough to
win what will end up being wave election
in the House by the time all the votes
are counted Republicans will have lost
nearly 40 seats in the house in this
last election cycle it turns out that
resident Trump has a lot of
vulnerabilities but if Democrats want to
distract themselves with myth stories
about how Hillary Clinton actually won
the election and it was the Russians the
evil nefarious Russians who stole from
from Hillary Clinton I mean I guess that
they can do that
it just seems wildly counterproductive
to me it doesn't seem like a smart
electoral strategy but you know this is
what the media do and speaking of what
the media do in just one second I want
to get to a new poll showing that
Americans are really quite unhappy with
the media and for quite good reason here
is the poll so there's a poll out today
and what it shows is that 7 is from
Zogby analytics it says that 72% of
Americans believe the media is dividing
Americans and spreading hate which I
don't know where the other 28% have been
but that obviously is true according to
Zogby 47% of Americans strongly agree
that the mainstream media has played a
major role in dividing Americans along
racial gender and political lines which
has led to a spread of hatred and
misunderstanding among some people and
it's 25% somewhat agree and 13% somewhat
disagree
16% strongly disagree so that means that
a huge number of Americans rightly
believe correctly believe that this is
that that the media have done an
incredible job dividing America and
that's largely because of me you have
done an incredible job dividing America
I mean they have al Sharpton out there
proclaiming that Trump has declared war
on minorities al Sharpton a guy whose
involvement in the 1991 Crown Heights
riots was pretty obvious to everyone and
a man who who shouted about Freddy's
fashion Martin some places burned down
and a few people were murdered
this guy is being trotted out by the
left I mean the guy still has a show on
MSNBC and he's talking about how Trump
has declared war on minorities we are
ready for action because we are an
administration that has declared war on
us and we want to know whose side
everybody's on am i right okay so
there's our Sharpton again not divisive
president Trump divisive in the media
treating Planned Parenthood as non
divisive right to the media the CBS this
morning had on the new head of plan
hood with the with the caption the
doctors in well the doctors in the womb
killing the baby is what the doctor is
in but the the this woman's name is
Liana when listen to the I mean this is
the most softball interview in history
for a woman who will be overseeing the
slaughter of hundreds of thousands of
unborn children every year here she is
being given the Royal carpet treatment
from the from the CBS this morning crew
well this is deeply personal to me I was
a patient in Planned Parenthood and so
was my mother and my sister just like
one in five women in America and as a
doctor I am proud to lead our
organization as we deliver life-saving
care to two and a half million people
every year and what I want to do is to
shape the future for my son
Eli and it's a future where all people
are treated the same that all people
have the right to health care and where
it's a society where we trust women
abortion is so nice and so happy
according to the media but don't worry
Trump's dividing the nation not the
media you know that this extends to
college campuses the sort of mentality
who's dividing the nation it's very
funny there was there's a letter that
was put out suggesting yesterday I spoke
at you know the Ohio State University
yesterday and there's a letter that was
put out by an aunt Eva associated group
in which the antifa associated group
basically suggested that I was divisive
they spelled divisive de VI which is not
how you spell the word divisive so I'm a
mostly divisive in my insistence on
proper spelling in any case and Tifa
said that I was divisive and then they
showed up and then they showed up
outside the lecture and the lecture was
not disturbed so they have every right
to do this obviously and fine if they
want to do this go for it
they showed up outside the lecture where
they chanted eff ben shapiro and also
chanted john mccain's dead and reagan's
dead really nice folks these members of
an Tifa it's a journalist kind of a
youtube journalist named plexus who
showed up at the at the rally outside
and asked a few pointed questions to
members of this rally guys this week
we're at Ohio State University for a yaf
speech Ben Shapiro is here and these
college kids are not happy about it
we're gonna see what's going on guys for
or against Ben
I think you should speak tonight or no
free speech of the Constitution has it
work you shouldn't be allowed to have
free speech if he's gonna preach the
kinds of things that he preaches well
where are some of the things that you're
talking about before against Ben Shapiro
because I mean the right to speak under
the Constitution they're yelling shut
Shapiro down the solid stuff from the
protestor they're not the one but I'm
the one who's divisive I love this this
is an email that was posted by the moral
scholars program Student Advisory
Council they said Shapiro's rhetoric has
the potential to threaten the emotional
and mental safety of much of the campus
community
they said that apparently might one of
the complaints that no one should
address a person by the pronouns they've
chosen for themselves which is not
something I've ever said actually when I
say instead is that you cannot force me
to to choose to use the pronoun that you
choose for me to use for you that is not
a thing that happens in a free country
but I'm the divisive one again and when
it comes to people who are divisive I
think that the the media has a lot
listen I'm not saying Trump and divisive
yes but the media are extraordinarily
divisive you know the people on campus
who are divisive are not people like me
the fact that one side is being called
divisive while the other side's divisive
'no sizz being ignored is it kind of a
problem
okay well time for a couple of things
that i like and then a couple of things
that I hate so things that I like today
so last week I had the opportunity to
sit down with Oren cast in advance of
his new book has a new book out and it's
called the once and future worker it's a
really interesting and I think useful
book he and I have some significant
disagreements on policy but Oren is one
of the better thinkers in the
conservative movement right now and one
of the better thinkers overall he's a
guy who actually is trying to address
some of the problems of folks who are
living in towns where jobs are being
lost where people are being left behind
and here's what that interview sounded
like so here we are four things I like
today I really wanted to talk with Oren
cast he's the author of the once and
future worker which is just a fantastic
book now as folks know when they listen
to or watch the show I never have guests
on the program like ever ever ever Oren
is the first guest I've had in months
and the reason for that is because Oren
is not only one of the most intelligent
commentators on the right he's somebody
who's actually thought through a lot of
deep policy-wonk issues having to do
with the future of the economy Oren
thanks so much for stopping by thank you
I'm glad we had a chair for me exactly
so the premise of the once and future
worker is that the kind of focus on free
trade globalization free markets all of
that is fine but it is missing the
central point of that that human beings
need labor in order to feel meaning I
wonder if you could talk about that a
little bit yeah that's exactly right you
know I think most of how we do economic
policy whether you're left of center or
right of center is just focused on
consumer welfare how do we get enough
stuff to people and how do we make sure
the amount of stuff you can buy
keeps going up over time and that's
important I don't want to minimize that
but what it leaves out is that people
don't care only or even mostly about how
much stuff they get it turns out that
people care a tremendous amount about
their ability to be a productive
contributor to have work that's
meaningful to them to be able to support
a family to be able to to pass those
values on to kids and when all you focus
on is the consumer side when you say
more free trade is always better no
matter what it does to our industry when
you say it doesn't really matter if
people are losing their jobs we can
write them a bigger check expand the
safety net you lose that and I think
that's what we've seen in America we've
gotten lots of GDP growth we keep
expanding the safety net and yet on the
things that really matter community
strength family formation mobility and
opportunity for kids that's not coming
along with it and I think it's because
we've lost that focus on work now on
that last point do you think that
there's a possible reverse correlation
meaning that we actually lost meaning in
churches and communities and then we
lost and then when the economic loss
hollowed the rest of it out then we see
this sort of raw depression across
the country do you think it's the lack
of jobs that leads to the decay of the
social fabric in other words the decay
of the social fat will predate the loss
of jobs or is it the loss of jobs that
creates decay of the social fabric I
think it goes both ways I think there
have certainly been a lot of trends
especially since the 1960s that are
contributing to the decay of the social
fabric and they compound each other I
think when you lose some of those other
very values oriented things you lose
people's commitment to working in some
cases but I think it runs the other way
also I think work really is foundational
to values transmission to people's
engagement and commitment to their
communities we know from very good
social science research that it is
incredibly important to family formation
especially for men it's really important
to family stability especially for men
and it's really important to the
outcomes that children have so I think
it's one of the key pieces and and
especially importantly if we're talking
about kind of policy what do we do I
think it's the one where we can actually
have effect I don't think we're gonna
have a bunch of policy reforms that get
people back into churches or that that
you know have those kinds of effects I
do think we can really do a lot more on
the policy front to build a labor market
that's gonna work for everybody no for
conservatives some of the sounds pretty
scary just from the top simply because
we had Tucker Carlson on the Sunday
special a few weeks ago and Tucker was
saying things like well in order to
preserve jobs let's just outlaw
automated driving and Bernie Sanders is
basically so we need to regulate the
economy train up the economy maybe make
the economy work for us and we'll take
the tame the power of the savage beast
and make it work for these jobs whereas
the the traditional sort of libertarian
view of economics the jobs are a
byproduct of consumerism that it's it's
it's essentially supply-side not the man
side so with that being the case where
do you draw the line as to what is the
policy balance I mean are we looking at
regulation of the economy are we looking
at tamping down free trade where are the
limitations that we're talking about
collectively putting on the economy that
scared the daylights out of people like
me no I think that's exactly the
question and and as you just said the
the options that we have on the table
that most people are talking about are
either let's just kind of keep doing
what we're doing and and do more
redistribution or let's somehow kind of
regulate and force force force the
market to be what we want it to and and
we know that that
or one let's just yell at the market
until we get saying we like doesn't work
you get worse outcomes but I think
what's really important to recognize and
and where libertarianism and
conservatism actually depart a little
bit is that the labor market or any
market it's just a neutral thing a
markets outcomes aren't inherently good
or bad they're just reflecting the
conditions that they're operating in and
if you're a libertarian you look at a
market outcome and you say whatever it
is it's good per se we like the market
outcome as the desired result
I think conservatism is a little bit
more nuanced than that and says markets
are a fantastic mechanism they protect
freedom and choice they promote
competition but if a markets landing in
a place that's bad for society that's
not maintaining our social endowments
and that's a problem and the labor
market is not like other markets because
the labor market is about people we
can't be indifferent to where the labor
market lands if where the labor market
is landing is in a place where a lot of
people don't have work or a lot of
regions can't find ways to stay viable
we can't say well that's the efficient
solution we have to say that's not good
enough but we don't say that's not good
enough and therefore yell at it we have
to take a step back and say what are the
conditions that are causing it to land
here and how can we change those
conditions in ways that would move it
somewhere else they can give me a couple
examples of that because it again it
seems like it's pretty easy to run into
sort of Bernie land here where you know
yelling at the market turns into actual
regulation of the market or turns into
high tariffs or a variety of policy
outcomes driven by you know let's make
the market work for people so what are
where were some examples of non
regulation and non redistributionist
measures that would actually help yeah
sure so one example is education and
recognizing that the way that we train
people as they are growing up is crucial
to who can work and what kind of work
they can do in the market our education
system today is focused entirely toward
producing college graduates our high
schools are essentially now College Prep
academies we push people into college we
massively subsidized keeping them there
and yet less than one in five people
actually go smoothly high school college
career everyone else falls out somewhere
along the way and if all you care about
is getting economic growth you could say
well look as long as those people who
make it through are productive enough
we're gonna be able to make everybody
happy but what if we actually care about
is is those folks who are falling out
along the way the people who are barely
completing high school the you know most
people still won't commute completed
Community College degree in this country
if the question is how can we make sure
that they are productive and can support
families also you would do education
differently you would say a much bigger
focus in our high schools needs to be on
people who aren't headed toward college
on getting people ready to be in the job
market giving them technical skills
actually getting them on the job and
learning what it means to have a job a
lot of the money that we spend
subsidizing college would be much better
spent subsidizing first jobs for people
getting them into the workforce making
employers want to invest in their
training and so that's not picking
winners and losers in the economy that's
not Bernie Sanders style you know I
order you to pay X amount that's saying
if we want a labor market that works for
more people what are we doing to equip
people to succeed in the labor market
well folks if you're interested in a
book that is filled not just with
problems but with actual attempts at
solutions the book is the once in future
worker orrin cast is the author one of
the best thinkers in America right now
orrin thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it thank you really
appreciate to so what makes or INRIA Lee
interesting is that you know he and I
disagree I think on a fundamental level
about what the labor market is for and
the goods and Bad's of the labor market
but he's actually attempting to come up
with some solutions in an open public
forum with open public debate and good
for him for doing that okay time for a
couple of quick things that I hate
so as I suggested it yesterday the media
we're going to wildly miss cover
everything that is currently happening
with regard to the Gaza Strip in Israel
there are 400 rockets that fell
yesterday in Israel no state worth its
salt would stand for this sort of thing
without significant blowback and that's
significant blowback has not even come I
mean Benjamin Netanyahu just had his
Defense Minister resigned on him because
the defense minister said that Netanyahu
wasn't doing enough to defend the State
of Israel
the New York Times however because the
New York Times New York Times is that
it's like boxing they they're explainers
are garbage
the New York Times explainer of what
just happened in Israel and Gaza doesn't
mention that Hamas is a designated
terrorist organization which seems to be
like you know the key to the whole thing
they don't mention the number of rockets
that were fired at Israeli civilians
which is a thing that is the entire
story so they don't mention that it's
chaos and they don't mention the number
of rockets which is the only reason we
are having the conversation at all once
again and when it comes to the media's
willingness to go along with radical
Muslim anti-semitism because it fits
into intersectional theory it's really
quite gross I'm going to talk about this
a lot at University of Pittsburgh
tonight but I think that it bears more
repeating because it's it's pretty
ridiculous on its face other things that
I hate today so this is just a terrible
story obviously there's been a lot of
media focus on a group of high school
students in Baraboo Wisconsin who are
holding up what appears to be a Nazi
salute this is Stephanie ruhle on MSNBC
talking about it I think it has a
graphic of the actual photo there's the
photo okay so the actual photo is a
bunch of kids some of whom seem to be
holding up their right hand in a Nazi
salute one kid in the front row is
giving the kind of the the okay sign
which has been interpreted as white
supremacist sign because 4chan white
supremacists decided they were going to
actually you know turn it into that so
there's debate over what exactly this
photo shows so the media have suggested
that this is all these kids joining in a
Nazi salute the journal the photo the
photographer he says that this was as
innocent as the boys and girls going to
the prom ghost son who's the he's the
photographer he is one of the his son is
one of the teens in the photo and he is
a retired teacher he said he told the
teens to
goodbye heading off to the prom for the
picture taken in May on the steps of the
South County Courthouse one of the teams
in the image Jordan blue canonic
contrary to that account he says that
gust instructed the group of mostly
white men to pose that way he said I
felt upset unsafe disappointed and
scared I felt unsafe because I go to
school with them I don't believe in what
they represented and the symbol they
shared they knew it was wrong but they
still did it so we don't actually know
what happened in this photo at this time
this group of overwhelmingly and nearly
indeed it appears to be universally
white kids in Upper Wisconsin throwing
the Nazi salute and some kids are not
some are but you know until we actually
hear all the facts it's hard to say all
these kids are actual Nazi sympathizers
here's where I think this is it's where
I think this is I think that people are
idiots I think people do idiotic things
a lot I don't think these kids are
actual white supremacist I think these
kids have a lot to learn about throwing
Nazi signs in a civilized society and
what that means to folks you know that
is actually a bad thing to do that even
when you do it pirata cailli you know
even when you are doing it as a joke
that it actually means something and
that it's a problem and that you
shouldn't be doing it and then it's
inherently offensive to throw a Nazi
salute this is not a thing that that
should really be joked about however do
I really think that these kids are like
going in the back room and they're
lighting up the tiki torches for Richard
Spencer or something no I don't I think
that probably what happened here is that
both things were true my guess is that
the photographer said to them guys wave
like you're about to go to prom right
now and then one of the kids said to the
other kids a man looks like we're doing
a Nazi salute and then the kids were
like ha ha ha ha ha ha ha they started
doing that right that that would be my
guess based on no evidence whatsoever
but is it true that people are ignorant
of history yes it is true that people
are ignorant of history is it true that
high school kids are stupid yes it is
true that high school kids are stupid is
it also true that we in this country are
going crazy over issues that should not
raise to this level but this should not
be a national issue when a couple in
some high school students to a dumb
thing that involve no violence against
anybody you know III think it's
overblown I think that it's as a person
who's not fond of Nazis right I think
that this is overblown and while these
kids need better education I'm not sure
why this is being featured on national
news broadcast when the local high
school has a bunch of students who are
17 years old were morons like
why is that why is that a thing and you
and when the story hasn't even been
fully fleshed out yet when basically
it's a couple of competing stories about
what exactly happened here okay so we
will be back here tomorrow tonight again
if you are over near Pittsburgh we are
speaking at the University of Pittsburgh
why I say we I mean the Royal we I am
and I'm gonna be like an athlete Ben
Shapiro is speaking at the University of
Pittsburgh so you can go check that out
tonight hope to see you there I mention
Farrell this is the bench capiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018